you
hey everybody new Punisher to break down
if you didn't know it's dropping in
November I have some theories about when
that's going to be they haven't said
officially but all signs are pointing
towards November 10th which is right on
the marine course birthday Frank Castle
was in the marine corps in Afghanistan
that's what you see in some of these
other clips like when they're walking
through those facilities when they have
the night-vision goggles on that's back
in Afghanistan so they'll be flashing
back and forth to the stuff that they
did over there like you've seen in the
other trailers that I've posted in
present day there's also a bunch of new
preview images that I'll break down to
just highlighting some of the different
cast members and especially Frank back
in Afghanistan and when he's with Mike
Rowe in his workshop with what looks
like the beginnings of his Armory in all
its full crazy glory he's been in sewers
he's been in dirty apartments he always
has the best armory obviously I'll be
doing bonus videos and episode videos
when it gets here just depending on what
kind of videos you guys want the Netflix
stuff is always a little bit different
so I tried to do that for defenders too
in the thor ragnarok take a giveaway
still going on - all you have to do to
enter that is just be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video I'll
announce a new winner at the end but if
you couldn't tell from the teaser
they're just hyping up this big
conspiracy that's set up by the
government and it looks like the CIA is
involved because that's who Rollins is
working for so he seems relatively
untouchable now that he's come back to
the United States one of the titles
implies you know patriotism is the
virtue of the Vicious which is this
famous Oscar Wilde quote and it's more
of a sinister connotation like Rollins
is the bad guy of the series and it
sounds like he's perpetrating all these
terrible things in concert with the CIA
and the government using patriotism is a
mask for his evil like it's a very
common theme and a lot of these
political thrillers or military
thrillers where you have very evil
people in positions of power in the
government of the military that
perpetrate all kinds of atrocities and
use patriotism as their excuse so it
sounds like the Punisher is going to be
uncovering some big conspiracy with the
help of Karen page and Mike Rowe so
that's why those classified documents in
that teaser read whistleblower with Mike
Rowe and Frank castles name right next
to each other but the rest of this
footage and a bunch of other teasers
they've been dropping
look more like surveillance footage so
that's probably where micro comes in I'm
guessing because he's like The Ultimate
Marvel Netflix man in the chair and he
used to work for the CIA or he still
works for them and is just helping Frank
castle on the sly he has access to all
this surveillance footage all this
technology so if you weren't already
afraid of the government spying on youth
and the Punisher series isn't gonna make
that any better
but I love some of these redacted
documents that they have in here like
this language reads Cerberus as
retaliatory and it sounds like it's just
part of some weapon or some special
strikes that they're doing but you see
homeland security down here but now you
kind of see how this is so different
from the stuff that was happening during
defenders why they want to do it as its
own thing for the first season before
Frank Castle becomes a defender himself
in future defenders seasons it yes there
will be a defender season two but a lot
of people were wondering including
myself about daredevil popping up during
this based on the end of defenders I
don't think that's going to happen just
based on where that character is and
where he's going to pick up in daredevil
season 3 because Karen pages the
crossover character we might hear about
Matt but I don't think we'll actually
see him on screen until we get to
daredevil season 3 which is probably
about a year away they don't start
filming till later this year so because
like Punisher is coming out this winter
I think the same is gonna happen with
daredevil season 3 next year around
November so they'll probably have a
daredevil trailer for comic-con next
year but just digging through the
punisher images that they posted so
probably the coolest one is him looking
at the body armor in micros armory which
looks like Punisher is going to co-op
then will become his armory because
they're working together but it'll be
interesting to see whether or not Mike
Rowe seeks Frank out or Frank seeks
micro out like who meets who first
because Punisher doesn't have access to
the kind of information that micro does
and Karen page might wind up being
something of an intermediary so you have
homeland security people on one side you
have the CIA on the other who seem more
like the bad guys and then you have
Frank Castle in the middle with all the
flashback stuff to his squad in
Afghanistan more of Karen page here this
site actually might look familiar from
daredevil season 1 this is actually
where the kingpin beat the crap out of
the Russian this is just Karen passing
information to the Punisher
probably seen a bunch of these images
from the sedges because they were
filming out an open-air there were a lot
of paparazzi that got shots of them last
year very clearly flashback to Kandahar
then we have Micro inside wherever his
warehouse is if this is anywhere close
to his house or if this is somewhere in
a different part of the city this sort
of confirms that the other teasers
they've been dropping the surveillance
footage teaser images are stuff that
Micro has been watching so it looks like
he's keeping an eye on either the CIA
people but there are also some images of
these cameras inside his own house with
his wife this is actually micros wife
here so it seems like he's watching
himself while he's also watching other
people which if you haven't read the
comics is very micro like imagine the
most paranoid version of Ned Leeds you
could possibly think of this is one of
our first looks at jigsaw post Kandahar
Afghanistan so like I said his backstory
in the punisher series in the Netflix
universe is that he used to be squad
mates and really good friends with Frank
Castle but jigsaw has formed a private
military company called anvil and that's
not a reference to anything in the
Marvel Universe I mean you could draw
references to Thor's hammer like hammer
anvil but really it just meant to sound
super hardcore if you were gonna hire a
private military company you wouldn't
hire somebody if they had a lame name
this person standing next to him here is
another miner Punisher villain called
Curtis Hoyle he was a lieutenant in the
army that crossed paths with Frank
Castle while they were in Vietnam
remember in the comics he's a veteran of
the Vietnam War but in the Netflix
universe its Kandahar and Afghanistan
and now he's working with jigsaw at this
mercenary company these are Sam Stein
and dynamo Donnie their homeland
security agents that are tailing Frank
because remember all the things he's
doing are very illegal in his pursuit of
justice so the common Punisher narrative
is still in play here where he's trying
to take down people that are even worse
than him he's still the hero of the
series but still winds up being
demonized by legitimate law enforcement
agencies so you have people like Karen
page that try to give him a voice and
show everyone hey he's not a villain
he's actually trying to help people even
though he's still killing a lot of
people this is just that Curtis Hoyle
character the one whose partner
with jigsaw trying to help out a younger
military vet that's having trouble
adjusting to life post military so
another one of the big issues that the
series will tackle is post traumatic
stress like it's a huge huge problem for
military vets and they dealt with it a
little bit during daredevil season two
but because this is so focused on a
military narrative you just see that a
little bit more but let me know in the
comments what are you guys most excited
for for the Punisher series and
everybody just wants to see him walking
around with the comic book costume on
just mowing through everybody I think
the biggest disappointment from him
during daredevil season 2 was the fact
that they released the promo with the
minigun that they never delivered on we
were promised a minigun so maybe we'll
get to see some of that during the
Punisher series but what'll happen later
tonight is is they'll probably be a new
arrow Deathstroke trailer for the first
episode of season 6 so look out for that
there's some new infinity war that's
dropped so I'll probably do a video for
that tomorrow and leave all your Marvel
video requests in the comments there'll
be all kinds of Marvel Thor stuff
dropping through the next couple of
weeks just expect a whole bunch of that
to start coming really soon
congratulations to last week's giveaway
winner Rafael Gregorian please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details
announce a new winner when I post that
infinity war video tomorrow but while
you wait for everything you can click
here for that other punisher trailer
video where I talk about the episode
titles and you can click here for the
brand new flash trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight